elizabeth day is a world-renowned
podcast host she's a best-selling author
she's a successful journalist
i felt like a failure but i probably
wasn't it was what i've been told to
feel
i've had countless failed relationships
and then it sucks like heartbreak there
is no pain like heartbreak
i now realize that i learned something
very instructive from each one of those
relationships
and from the fact that they ended it
taught me something that i needed to
know
about myself infertility and miscarriage
is not a mishap
like for people who experience it it's a
tragedy over which they have no control
and the idea that i was exploiting it to
make a full-time career out of it
was so insulting because i know how
[ __ ] painful and traumatic it is to
go through
[Music]
being vulnerable something i think we
all find it incredibly hard to do
and after hearing my guest's story today
i had tears in my eyes maybe three or
four
times and that's because she is willing
to be
vulnerable and honest and open about her
truth her trauma
and the things she's learned from her
most testing times elizabeth day is a
world-renowned podcast host she is a
best-selling author
she's a successful journalist honestly
she's quite frankly one of the most
wonderful smart lovely people i've ever
had the privilege of doing this podcast
with
in fact today one of the issues i had
with this podcast was we agree on
so much that it's hard to play devil's
advocate with her it was hard to
challenge her
views because so many of them
represented mine it felt like she was
reading out of my book
i think that's powerful because she
helped me build on my ideas
and some of these ideas are
controversial for some people may be too
controversial
it is remarkable how much societal
expectations can
[ __ ] your chance of happiness and i
genuinely believe that if we had more
people in the world like elizabeth
who were willing to say what she says
today then maybe that wouldn't be the
case
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the divers ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
one of the things that i wrote recently
which um
after doing a little bit of reading
about your story and your journey really
really resonated with me
um was this idea that the
society's expectations of how your life
is supposed to be going will [ __ ] you up
and when i think about you know you've
written this amazing book about called
philosophy about failure
i was thinking what is objectively like
what is failure and
um my conclusion was that failure is
like a byproduct of social expectations
um that's and as is success so
could you talk to me a little bit about
how social expectations
have made you feel like a failure
of course yeah i realized i had to
define failure after i had launched a
podcast called how to fail and after i
had written a book called how to fail
and then i kept getting asked this very
reasonable question
and i realized i'd never come up with a
satisfying definition
for me so the definition i came up with
in philosophy
is that failure is what happens when
life doesn't go according to plan
which totally taps into what you've just
asked me about because then you need to
start to think
well where does the plan come from is it
genuinely my plan
is it genuinely will make me happy or is
it what i've been told
i should expect my life to be because
when i looked at some of my metrics for
how my life
should be and i put that in quotation
marks it kind of came from like 1980s
rom-coms
and and patriarchal society and
conditioning
and the idea that i've been raised in
the 80s to be a nice
pleasant pliable girl whereas boys were
enabled to be mischievous and that was
seen as kind of cute and charming
and that led to me being an investor at
people pleaser which i know is something
that a lot of people
have in this kind of industry and it
also led to me
imagining that i wanted to be married
and have children
and that's what i tried to do and in my
30s i did get married to the wrong
person i ended up getting divorced and i
tried but failed to have babies and went
through various fertility treatments
that were
emotionally devastating in various ways
and it got to a point when i was 36
divorced didn't have children where i
really did feel like a failure
and the reason i felt like a failure is
because
that's what society had conditioned me
to believe of myself because actually
after i'd got over the pain and the
grief caused by that
seminal relationship ending and by all
of the ivf and coming to terms with my
first miscarriage and all of that
i actually felt strong for having
withstood it
and i actually felt kind of liberated
too because
i had no plan for the future and having
no plan for the future can be terrifying
and it can also be this enormous
opportunity
to change your life and to redefine it
according to who you
really are once you've stripped back
that pretense
so that's one way in which
i felt like a failure but i probably
wasn't it was what i've been told to
feel
so i wanna i wanna like pick around this
a little bit because i
can resonate with this tremendously in
fact that's why my book is has the name
it does is because
i was conditioned as a black kid who was
broke
to believe that the thing that would
make me a success was becoming this
happy sexy millionaire with a range
rover and i mean so i wrote the front
page of my diary
that you know that's a kid from africa
who in africa had nothing but was
you know my family were happy bring that
kid into a context or a con
yeah a context where the context is
telling me that unless you're this
you should feel like [ __ ] um that's why
as a kid i was like well i need to happy
sexy minute to be fair if i'd wrote
something else it would have been white
straight hair right i was relaxing my
hair chemically
from the age of about 12 till about 16
so my hair was straight
but i want to i want to go back to this
this point about society telling you
um what you should want did you ever
figure out what you actually wanted
such a good question also thank you for
sharing what you just did
yeah because i know that yeah you
believe like i do that vulnerability is
the source of connection true connection
and that was really beautiful um i
think i have figured out who i am now
but i sit here as a 42 year old having
only just figured that out
and the reason i figured it out is
because of all of those things that went
wrong
those relationships that ended that
imploded the jobs that weren't right for
me like that was what prompted me to do
the soul searching
and i'm a big believer in things
happening for a reason the universe
unfolding as is intended even if you
can't
make something meaningful as and when
it's happening because it's traumatic
and it's devastating
i tend to believe that there will be
some meaning in there in the fullness of
time there'll be something that i needed
to learn
i wish sometimes i'd learnt the lessons
more quickly because i believe i kept
being sent the same lessons until i
really really learned the the thing that
i needed to learn
but i do think now that i'm aware of who
i
am because i've redefined
my notion of success so in the past
my success was not necessarily being a
happy sexy millionaire although
i wouldn't say no in the past
i had a very different
contextual upbringing from yours
and i'm immensely privileged in many
ways and one of the ways in which i am
privileged is that there was a lot of
kind of
creativity and um cultural discussion in
my home like
i was surrounded by books i was never
taught to feel that that was odd that i
read all the time or that i wanted to be
an author even though there was no one
in my family who did that
so i had those kind of conversations and
that's and that's an enormously
wealthy way to be brought up and i even
though we didn't have that much money
that was very wealthy and so for me then
success was about doing well at school
it was doing well academically
and i realized that when i did well on
an exam i got approval
and that for me became a substitute for
self-worth
so for a long time i was on this
feedback loop where i was like if only i
could just do better and do better at
more things
eventually i'll feel i'm worthwhile
and i was on a hiding to nothing because
actually i was outsourcing my sense of
self to everyone else's opinions of me
and to kind of external validation and
i've now realized and it's taken me a
long time to realize this that
my only validation that means anything
can come
from within and from my cornerstone
relationships so like the four or five
people i love most in the world
whose opinion actually means something
to me that's what it is
now having worked that out how can i
bring my authentic self into every area
of my life
and that's why the podcast has felt and
the books about failure
have genuinely been such a gift to me
because they've enabled me to connect
with a really big audience
whilst being my true self whilst taking
the risk
to be vulnerable and that for me is
success
being my authentic self in integrated
selves so
like professionally personally and when
i'm asleep
like i'm or in my friendship group or
when i'm stroking my cat it's always the
same me
i talk in so i hate [ __ ] plugging my
own book but it's
the reason i'm doing it is because we
very much think the same
and one of the chapters in my book is
about making your um your context
smaller and healthier in an age of
social media where i can compare myself
to
a billion people who are all filtering
themselves and fake
i implore like people to make their
context which is what you've described
there's like four or five people
much smaller like unfollowing me all the
toxic people in your
like comparison bubble or whatever and
make it tight and healthy
that's so hard these days
if you're on social media platforms and
following like the kardashians or
whatever
how does how does one do that and also
stay on social media like
well i need to ask you this so i'm going
to ask you this after i've tried to
answer it because
i'm i'm you have to deal with it on such
a massive scale and i'm just like
a micro tiny thing in comparison no i
don't think that's fine
but the way to answer that truly
honestly i'm still
a huge work in progress in that respect
because
i have the capacity to be undone by
criticism like i fi
i take it really really personally tell
me how personally give me an example
so personally give me an example okay um
two recent examples one is that
i went um a few weeks ago i went on a
lockdown walk
with a friend of mine who i haven't seen
for over a year socially distanced
it was my daily exercise i was allowed
to do with one person from another
household
and i posted a picture of us socially
distanced in a park
on instagram being like you know this
was really good for my
mental health such an enjoyable walk and
someone commented saying i can't this is
so irresponsible of you
to post this because hospitals are
overwhelmed with covered patients
and you're encouraging people just like
go out and about and i was like hang on
a second
i was like that's where i go with it oh
my god i've done something wrong
i've done something wrong and these poor
nhs doctors who are working and i've
just
kicked them in the face metaphorically
and i was and i had this process of like
i've done something wrong i'm a terrible
person i feel really bad about it
what can i do should i reply i go
through that that's the first place i go
and then i tell myself no leave it 24
hours
leave it 24 hours before you say
anything and then i just feel
i have this like harness that settles
around me for a day
of feeling unsettled
and a bit worried and anxious
and are other people thinking that is
there a whole group of people out there
that they're like meeting up behind
closed doors to discuss how awful i am
launching your council campaign like oh
yes and it's ridiculous
yeah it's awful and i saw other people
had liked that comment i was like oh my
god they hate me too
i'm and basically i just have to sit
with it for a bit and
it helps me to talk about it even though
i sound completely
doolally but i do i'm lucky enough to
have an incredible resource
in my husband who is just not on social
media at all and so it's a very kind of
sane mind to bring to it
and my best friend who's a
psychotherapist and i spoke to her about
it and she was like okay where i would
go with it
is what pain is that person in that
they've lashed out in this way
and that's very helpful because it
encourages you to feel compassion
instead of got at and anger i mean
that's one tiny example another example
was
philosophy got reviewed in a couple of
places and i
you know i i'm really proud of that book
but it's a physically small book i mean
it's got a lot of good content in it
don't get me wrong and as you know it's
hard to make big ideas accessible
but i did not expect it to get reviewed
in the national press
but it did and it got reviewed by people
who wanted to find fault with it
who did not like the fact that
i seemed to be exploiting failure for my
own success which is
absolutely not the case like i want to
share the stuff
that i've learned that's all i wanted
exploiting
failure for your own success [ __ ]
house anyway so that was that was just
like i went down a rabbit hole of
looking at the reviewers instagram and
all of that sort of stuff which is
terrible anyway i know i shouldn't go
down these
rabbit holes of self-loathing and most
the time i'm able not to
but just occasionally if i'm feeling low
or
particularly sensitive that day it will
affect me
and my tactic for protecting myself
is absolutely of you said as you said to
unfollow and mute to curate my feed
to keep my phone on airplane mode in the
morning so my phone is not the first
thing i look at
when i'm writing i put my phone on
airplane mode as well and i find it a
real relief
and also to try and practice the art of
generosity and to believe in abundance
because i think a lot of my mindset
around competitiveness or envy
is because i believe in a scarcity of
resources and i believe success is
scarce
and i believe money is scarce and love
is scarce and we all have to compete for
it yeah like is there some game
exactly and actually just flipping the
switch and being like
no the world is abundant
and everyone's success can mirror your
own
like and if you give and if you come at
life from a generous place
then hopefully that will feed back to
you so those are my
tactics interesting how do you deal with
it
um so i think it's important to be
honest as well i'm
i've read a lot about this this topic
i've spoken to psychologists i've sat
here with guests and you know
ask them about this and this is probably
maybe a liberating but also a terrifying
answer
eve and i have exactly what you've
described it feels so much better
do you know what's funny the reason when
i was laughing you when you said to me
you went oh i know it sounds cucky i was
laughing because it's you
telling me my life oh you know what i
mean like i will i will get
one comment on one thing and i'll be
like
let's look at this jonathan davis and
find out all about you know what i mean
his family are it'll be just it's just
like flipping comment
surrounded by a thousand positive ones
but i'm like i'm gonna find this
guy's birth records and we're gonna find
out you know what i mean like private
investigator
and the way you describe that feeling of
like it bothers you you're like shall i
respond sometimes i respond i'm like
then i delete it super fast because i'm
like
you know you rise above and then i've
also felt in the bigger moments where
something more controversial has
happened i've also felt that like thing
around me
for about like 48 hours yeah that
feeling of like anxiousness
yeah like you described like wait does
is this does everyone
you think all your all my friends that
are quiet they all think that i've
i'm finished you know what i mean
they're not saying anything am i adopted
yeah he's like yeah so here's my
he's my productive conclusion though is
one of the things we're not taught to do
is to use social media in a conscious
way
so we like sign up and then we just go
with the algorithm and the algorithm
will be like
be pretty or and then they'll clap for
you good good and it'll be like you do
this and we cut and
then it will tell us to follow lots of
people who we compare ourselves to and
create this really unhealthy context
in which we our self-worth is clearly
our
you know achievements success and beauty
is clearly less than all of these people
and because it's so unconscious we
become a victim to the algorithms and to
this
this like awful toxic experiment so
the the answer for me is just to use
social media in a much more conscious
way you've described it there which is
like unfollow people that are bad for
you turn off your notifications
um when i on twitter when i do a tweet
and it goes like semi-viral
i know that for the next 48 hours i'm
gonna get all kinds of twitter eggs and
all
so i just mute it straight away i did it
last night i did a tweet start getting
all these responses
hit me and it's disappeared yeah i don't
see any response
and this is the like conscious you know
effort that i have to make to keep my
context healthy and to protect myself
yeah do you know i had a really
interesting experience
on twitter recently and it's it's it's
fascinating because i think i care less
about twitter
because i don't feel as myself on
twitter i suppose because i'm super
conscious of how you can send out an ill
tweet one day and like lose everything
the next instagram
rightly or wrongly just feels safer it
feels more like a warm bath whereas
twitter's like a kind of
shower of hail a lot of the time and
but on recently on twitter someone
messaged me saying oh that thing that
was in the times magazine about you was
so unfair
and i hadn't read it and i then went and
looked at the article
and it was an interview with another
author
and the journalist had said had compared
this person to
me and a couple of other people and said
you know now there's this trend
i'm paraphrasing for people to use their
mishaps
and exploit them and turn them into
full-time careers with non-stop webinars
and instagram lives and she said like
like
elizabeth day with infertility and i was
like
that sits so badly with me because
infertility and miscarriage is not a
mishap like for people who experience it
it's a tragedy over which they have no
control and the idea that i was
exploiting it to make a full-time career
out of it with non-stop webinars and
i've done a webinar in my life by the
way
was so insulting to me because i had a
career
apart from that and before that and it's
that i choose to use my platform to talk
about something that a great deal of
people feel
a great deal of misplaced shame over and
that was
one example in fact the only one i can
think of where i did respond
because it was so deeply
deeply personal to who i was and i felt
an attack on my integrity and a complete
misreading
of what i was trying to do and i tweeted
something that was really calm
and that was like you know i refute this
for these reasons
and it was an excellent lesson in how
sometimes it is important to stand up
for something
i had an outpouring of incredible
support
from other people who i'd never met
which meant a great deal to me
the journalists in question had the
grace afterwards to apologize
but they changed the wording and the
online piece and if i hadn't
sent out that tweet there would be no
record of it having happened
and these things are really important to
call out sometimes so i think when it's
an attack
on the integrity of who you are and what
you do
then sometimes it is worth drawing
breath and saying something calmly and
just stating your position
and in that case as well you're the
courage shall i say to speak about to
have that vulnerability
creates a culture where more people will
speak out and it's that and that is so
powerful and helpful for so many other
people who are going through that and
can't
and can't find um a voice that they can
relate to and
you could you know create that sense of
um understanding by by hearing your
story same with the mental health
um conversation over the last 10 years
if people weren't speaking about it
the place would be and is quite
terrifying to think of and you wouldn't
say those people
have exploited it right so it's just i
mean it's such a nonsense
thing for someone to write that i
actually don't want to spend too much
time talking about it
quick one starting from the minute the
lockdown is lifted we're going to start
bringing in some of our subscribers to
watch how this podcast is produced
behind the scenes
means you get to meet the guests meet
myself and see how we put all of this
together
if you want that to be you all you've
got to do hit the subscribe button
so let's talk about people pleasing yeah
you said you're a people pleaser
yes well i'm a reformed people please i
guess you used to now don't give a [ __ ]
what you thought
okay i really do um yes
so i like many women of my age was
raised in the 80s and early 90s in a
culture
where it was still very very gender
stereotyped i mean we've come
so far in the last decade
i think in understanding that but
as a result i always thought that my
worth as a person was predicated on
keeping other people happy so i
got into a series of long-term
monogamous relationships from the age of
19 to 36 like that
the biggest gap between those
relationships was like a month
no because i was like who am i unless
i'm
making someone else happy unless i'm
being someone else's perfect partner
unless i'm i'm trying to second-guess
what they might want for dinner and
when they ask me like where do i want to
go for lunch i don't know where would
you like to go like that was my life it
was ridiculous
and it manifested itself at work as well
i was always the person
who said yes to overtime yes to the
commissions that no one else wanted
because i thought eventually i'd be
rewarded
and i got a staff feature writer job at
the observer a sunday newspaper in the
uk
when i was 29 and i was the youngest
feature writer there and so i felt
really intimidated
and so part of my constantly saying yes
and showing willing was to try and fit
in and be accepted
and actually you just become an easily
exploitable asset
and i realized after eight years of that
job that i was never going to
be moved anywhere i did ask i asked for
like different roles different
challenges
and the answer was always no and it was
because
i was i was doing too much where i was
like why would they want to move me
i was providing them with an excellent
service where i was i was making myself
too indispensable and i was absolutely
refusing to complain that's what's going
to say you ain't going to complain never
and never ask for a pay rise stephen i
mean
which is actually makes me feel slightly
sick now looking back because
i am a feminist and i do believe women
should ask for
the pay that they deserve but i didn't i
was too intimidated
and um ultimately i think people
pleasing can start
from a desire to be nice and to think of
others and that's a really beautiful
thing
but taken to its extreme which is where
i would put myself
it actually becomes very selfish because
you never take the time to know who you
truly are
and that leads you into situations and
relationships
that you shouldn't be in because you're
not fully giving yourself
you're giving a version of perfection to
someone
that is never fully real yeah so i never
felt able to show
who i really was and and that's the
state of mind i got married in
and little wonder that it ended is that
why you think it ended
part of the um part of the reason like i
definitely found it very difficult to
find my voice
for a long time what does that mean in a
relationship
um it meant that i was extremely
conflict avoidant
so instead of saying how i felt about
something
i would turn it inwards and be silent
and then get mildly depressed
so that's a difficult person to be with
they don't seem difficult at all because
they're like look i've cooked you dinner
and i've got all your favorite things
and i've
come up with this perfectly thoughtful
gift for christmas
but that's all like distraction it's all
like just don't look at the
mess i actually am inside um so i had to
do
a lot of work on myself it was part of
the reason it wasn't the whole reason
um there was a whole pile of other stuff
that i can't go into because it involves
someone else
but that was definitely like i do think
that when a relationship ends
you have to look at yourself and be
really honest about
how you played into that dysfunctional
dynamic to avoid making the same
mistakes
i'm not in a relationship i've actually
really struggled with relationships and
i was thinking about this last
night when i was working out i was
thinking much the reason why i've
struggled
is because i think i'm probably too
selfish right
i think that i'm uncompromising as well
and it's something that i've tried over
the last couple of years to really look
like
defeat in myself which is in in work i'm
required to be a certain type of person
to succeed which is like quite
certain about the right approach focused
hard working
um a lot of things in the professional
environment
aren't actually democratic they're like
the big decisions they they lack you the
buck stops with you
um in relationships um communication
and compromise and being more democratic
in things
and really trying to meet um someone
else's needs
are the i guess the attributes for
success
yeah communication let's talk talk about
that how important
is it to um from your experiences in
relationships that have you know gone
done well by your definition and ended
by your definition
um to communicate how you're feeling and
what your needs are
it's so important it's everything i'm
very interested
in what you just said there so i'm going
to come back to that question you asked
me
the the fact that you have that you
believe you might need different modes
of communication
in business and in personal
relationships slightly different
and this is like super controversial
because because people will
think that so communication is
incredibly important in my professional
life
yeah it's actually the things things
like so in my in my professional life
if i don't want to do something or if i
think it's a bad use of my time i say
no don't don't do it cancel it whereas
in my romantic life you can't do that if
i don't want to do so
i don't want to go down and walk walk in
the park but i've got to be like
fine yeah you know what i mean and and i
can be i'm supe in my
in my professional life i'm a radical
about how i spend my time
because i because you get so many things
calling for your time you have to be
like nope nope nope cancel it move it
nope no no
in my professional life it's like what
do you want to do do you want to cook
for two hours
um fine you know and and i got my brains
like wasted is that an efficient use of
time you know
so interesting because in your
professional life as well you're in a
position where you need to know the
answers someone will come to you for a
decision you need to know
you need to be like a benign dictator
and just be like right this that
and and therefore do you think that in
your personal life
you don't think it's okay to say
i don't know i don't know if i want to
okay
it's like a compromise of like not doing
things i don't want to do so don't do
things you don't want to do
this is so interesting so my my now
partner husband
is amazing and he's a ceo and he
said to me in the early days of my
relationship i never do anything i don't
want to do and i was like
selfish i was like i'm a people pleaser
so
this is never going to work um but
he's the knock-on effect of that
basically what he was saying is
i'm honest and i will tell you if i
don't want to do something so if i say
yes
that yes is really meaningful and that's
such a weight like it's such a weight
off my mind because i'm not having to
second guess whether he really means it
when he says he'll come for lunch with
my family or whatever yeah i know that
he's invested in that
so actually i'm your husband for a
second okay
i go you say to me i'd love to go and
walk in the park and i go
nah i want to sit on my laptop and send
these emails
and then five minutes and ten minutes
late you go oh i would love to cook with
you and he goes nope i want to
watch youtube videos about spacex okay
so i'm your wife and i say
i completely understand that because
you're having a really heavy week at
work
i'd really like to go to the park
because i really want to spend quality
time with you
and it would make me feel sad if we
didn't do that
then what would you say yes yeah there
you go and do you think you'd want to
say yes
of course i would yeah there you go of
course i don't know why i always fail on
this thing i just think
the amount of time and attention um my
previous partners have um have asked of
me i've not been able to
deliver and i'm like i will go i'll text
maybe once a day when i'm in my when i'm
in like the tornado of the business
yeah you'll say like justice is that
really yeah and like
it doesn't mean i don't love you it
means that i'm in a mild crisis
which i can't tell you about because i
haven't got time to like divulge all of
my [ __ ] so
sorry how you're really young aren't you
how old are you 20
28 now yeah and you're dating your age
group i'm assuming
typically a little bit younger like yeah
you see that that
it's that's very difficult it's so
difficult dating in your 20s
anyway full stop but when you're you
and you're basically living the life and
you have the wisdom of
a 45 year old that's very difficult
because the other person hasn't had that
life experience yet to know
oh you're so right yes you're right
honestly you're sorry i'll set you up
for 85 years
is the be or end all for me and
when i met justin who is now my husband
it was a really difficult learning
process for me because he had a very
different mode of communication but he
because he is a founder and a ceo and he
didn't have time to text me and i
[ __ ] love text i'm a writer that's
what i don't i hate a phone call i've
had to get used to it now in the global
pandemic
but i would hate a phone call i always
think i've done something wrong
whereas justin was always like why would
i take time to text you
when i can just call you and convey the
necessary information
necessary information honestly and he
said this thing well and i kept bringing
it up and i was like
if he if i don't hear from you for like
three days
that's really upsetting to me and it's
not gonna work if that continues he's
like okay i hear that
he's like for me text is a very cheap
form of communication
and it's something you do when you don't
really care and i do it a lot for work
so for me it's much more important to
spend time together anyway
we've sorted it out and i think that's
about having different
love languages and i made him take the
quiz and it was really helpful
he was acts of service oh no way but he
was awesome
yeah there you go it's what you do oh
that's so
but he was also he wasn't interested in
words of affirmation at all which is
mine
i might just compliment me all the time
was he touch yes
i thought sorry so am i oh my god you're
literally like the same person
yeah that's yeah and i was when he took
that i was really surprised it was quite
early days of our relationship and he
hadn't given me the impression of
needing touch
and then once i knew that i was like oh
that's lovely because
i like that too are you quality time and
there's quality times one of them yes
and words of affirmation
yes i'm totally so i was totally words
of affirmation when we took
the test but i think that's because i'd
come off a
a really bad patch of relationships
where i didn't feel
safe in those relationships so i was
constantly looking
for something to paper over the cracks
and for me that papering came in the
form of compliments
that was like the easiest thing to ask
for
and so that's what i thought i needed
but now actually in my relationship i
feel really safe
so for me it is quality time it's still
worth affirmation but quality time
is super important and and i now realize
that
justin is very good at taking feedback
that's because that's the business brain
isn't it
yeah yeah you have so i don't need to
sugarcoat something i can say
listen i need this or i feel this and
sometimes he'll need time i hope he
doesn't like me
he's so private but sometimes he'll need
times like uh
think it through and sort of strategize
it and like
digest it and i always know it's never
that he's forgotten he'll come back and
he'll be like right i agree
and this is the action that we're going
to take and it's amazing and i love that
i really love that i used to think it
was unromantic it's not at all
it's the most romantic thing because i'm
being taken really seriously
and i'm guessing this is a guess but i
do say it to him without
too much like emotion because he sounds
like a very pragmatic guy
so the way that i like to receive
feedback like that from my ex was
just very like without blame or like
um too much emotion and just like here
are the facts yeah that's the best way i
like to receive you back you know
yes completely but do
separate to you getting feedback if your
partner is emotional
and is crying at a film or is sad about
something so
moved to tears or feeling anxious so
therefore yes that's fine
exactly the same it's just the feed you
know because you know what i mean you do
you
want it with judgment yeah and you in
his business i'm sure he'll deal with
people all day
who give him feedback in a very
practical pragmatic way and that's the
way you could come used to it and
he'll have the same problem as me
whereas sometimes in business you'll get
feedback in a very
quite unhealthy and a helpfully
emotional way yes and
now you're trying to deal with us you're
not sure which issue you're actually
dealing with right
so when you present it without the
emotion i understand what i'm aiming at
here it's the same as me yeah
i feel like a bit of a scumbag for
having uh acts of service as my
no that's a really lovely thing but
doesn't it sound cheap it's like i would
like you to serve me with
you know what i mean yes i was going
through that love language thing and i
was thinking
why is it that someone getting me
something that they knew would help me
doing something that they knew would
help me
means so much to me because for me that
because because my life is tough and
challenging
i see it as them showing
an action which is action speak louder
than words how much they cared about
helping me yeah
and for me that's like i'm like oh god
you know and also probably because
you've had to be incredibly
self-sufficient yeah yeah you were like
the definition of a self-starter you've
had to rely on yourself
so much that for someone else to step in
and be like i've got this for you
it means a lot it's so meaningful and
you're carrying so much so if someone
comes and says oh yeah i carry one of
these bags for you it's like oh thank
you yeah
you know what i mean i totally get it
interesting
one of the things you said was that
you're you were i guess um
scared of being lonely at the end of
your life oh my gosh yes that's my
existential fear that and pigeons still
interestingly the global pandemic
has been so tough and so much tougher
for so many people than it has been for
me
in myriad ways one of the unexpected
side benefits
is that i've really got comfortable with
my fear of loneliness
because overnight my diary was
totally empty so i had no social
engagements i
couldn't see friends and it made me
realize that i didn't really want to see
the majority of people that i was going
to see
like i'd said yes to social situations
that i didn't really want to go to but i
felt like i should and i didn't want to
offend someone by not letting them down
that's still the people pleaser in me um
and having the freedom
to choose who i wanted invest time in
was hugely beneficial for me because i
realized actually that
my core my nucleus of people is very
very small
and actually if i've got justin
and my best friend i'm good i'm good
and beyond that you know my closest
friends like i
actively want to see them and but i
realized that i was just spending a lot
of time
not nurturing those friendships because
i knew that i would be able to step back
into them and i knew that i'd be
accepted because that's the level of
great friendship isn't it like you're
just always welcome back
and i was spending a lot of time trying
to nurture these other ones that were
less meaningful to me that required more
of it because
they weren't as generous in their
acceptance of me so
actually my fear of loneliness has
slightly lessened now
it's good news yes isn't it and although
you probably can't tell i am
actually an introvert but i've
successfully learned
how to be extrovert and how to
um pretend i'm confident when i don't
feel it and all of that sort of stuff
and i've realized that
i'm also pretty resilient when my world
shrinks
so i think i'm going to be okay
silver lining yeah on that point of
confidence it's something that people
ask
me about all the time which is
confidence seems to be one of the great
barriers of people
pursuing themselves as you describe
pursuing their dreams pursuing who they
are
some people will know who they think
they are but they don't have the
confidence to take the leap
per se are you confident
um yes in certain things
so i'm confident that i can write
i'm now confident that i can podcast
i can do a good podcast um you're a
great talker i was thinking this as
you're speaking i'm thinking
i was thinking yeah because i understand
why she has a really good podcast oh
thank you
very you know you're very like
articulate self-aware but you're really
good at you know talking
yeah it's like a strange thing to say
yeah you know you are well
i think i'm good at connecting with
people
and that's something that i
really cherish because that's where all
the good stuff lies for me like i love
having a conversation like this on such
a real
level with someone and connecting that's
heaven to me
like this is introversion heaven
it's like i don't want to be a big party
like trying to have this conversation
with you like that would
be stressful um so i'm confident
there and you'll notice that those are
all things that i do
i'm not hugely confident
about myself
in the sense that i still
struggle with self-worth and i realized
that that
probably sounds really nauseating for me
to sit here in this lovely place being
interviewed for this fabulous podcast
drinking my cup of middle-class green
tea like it sounds absurd for me to say
that and also self-indulgent
but that's me being really honest like
i've just got
that that's something that uh
i really struggle with like just feeling
that i'm enough
interesting so the conclusive chapter in
my book chapter 20
is all about this topic okay yeah yeah
and and i and i
because i think i you know i spoke to
some psychologists and stuff and i
batted around with this idea of um
this contradiction of how i could
possibly be enough but ambitious
yeah yes do you know what i mean like i
know it feels like a contradiction
yeah and that's that thing that i always
fear if i
if i tackle my self-worth and i cure
myself will i just have
no drive okay so this is chapter 20.
okay and it's crazy because you would
have you'll
resonate with this yeah i actually
started the chapters
set out to answer the question and i
answered as i was typing
and and so usually as you'll discover
like in the book is
um a lot of the time it's just a shitty
use of words that are holding us back so
one of the things like is you know is he
your soul mate that there's so many
presumptions within that like that
you're that a soulmate exists you have
one of them you'll be able to find them
um and in fact if you ask yourself maybe
the concept of a soulmate doesn't
actually exist
same thing with are you enough right so
the term enough
this was my conclusion first assumes
that we can become less and more yeah
how can we become less and more that's a
good point
in in innately and intrinsically how can
we ever
how can elizabeth ever be intrinsically
innate like
inside less or more you're always going
to be you same hair
same arms same legs same talent same
skills you
inherently like intrinsically never
change
yeah you never become less more enough
you just are
the the reason why we have these metrics
again is because it's an external
extrinsic comparison so i am
not enough my nokia is not enough
alongside an iphone so i thought in fact
and then when you have that feeling of
like being less and more of enough
what you then pursue is the pursuit of
becoming
more but because it was driven by
external factors
your ambition becomes externally driven
so for me i didn't think i was enough so
i
was trying to get a lamborghini and in
fact it's the belief it's the knowing
that you never become less moral enough
that intrinsic feeling that makes you
pursue ambition the right things for the
right reasons
so once i knew i was enough i then went
after things i actually gave a [ __ ]
about intrinsically
i stopped going after lamborghinis and i
started going after like
i would love to do a book i would love
to learn piano
and so my conclusive point is that in
fact it's the it's the knowing that
you're enough and that in fact you never
become less or more regardless of what
you achieve or accomplish
that is the foundation of real ambition
yeah real ambition is for you
it's chasing what you want for your
reasons that was my conclusion
so the enough thing is actually [ __ ]
which is just social which
then causes [ __ ] ambitions like
lamborghinis yeah
and uh realizing that you never you know
you never become less more
or enough intrinsically allows you to
have intrinsic ambitions and that is
real ambition that's my conclusive point
which is so so mind-blowingly good and
also connects to that whole thing
that [ __ ] about soul mates yeah
because there's that belief that a
soulmate will complete you now what are
you saying there you're saying that
you're incomplete
in and of yourself yeah and that there's
only one true way
to like all of that i hate that yeah the
question comes in a very innocent way
it's like is he your soul mate
and yes the moment you accept it but you
also accept seven other pieces of
unintended [ __ ]
which is like that you're incomplete now
that you you've done
you're a failure at not finding this
person and all of these other pieces of
[ __ ] it's the same with like i
for me it's the same as like are you in
love or have you found your passion
have you found your passion is it like a
i posted about this other day it's like
another just
really difficult piece of [ __ ] um to
to comprehend because
found i've got to search for it my
passion there's one of them and it's out
there somewhere and once i find it
it's going to feel great passion what's
that how does that feel
you've said the word are we thinking of
the same thing the same
so many pieces of [ __ ] which i now
have to accept so
if there was one thing that i've learned
in the last couple years it's just like
question the question yeah as much as
you possibly can because the question
will [ __ ] you when you accept it oh my
gosh i could not agree more
like also passion
[Music]
is such an unhelpful word it's that
thing of like oh
did you feel did you feel passionate did
you feel this sexual insane sexual
chemistry did you fall in love at first
sight
and i'm like hang on a second what
you're saying there is did you feel
deeply unsettled and chaotic yeah
because that's what passion it's like a
disruptive force
i'm like i don't want to feel i don't
want to feel unstable and chaotic i want
to feel
safe and known that for me
is like true romance yeah and a
relationship
or a business is not a failure because
it ends
again like you could have learned so
much you could have learned what you
needed to know and therefore you can
evolve and grow
yeah and as you say the act of finding
something what if it's like
inside you don't need to be yes
something you love to do
should be something you'd love to do
without having to go on this quest yeah
exactly yeah yeah
but that's what you were saying earlier
about ambition being an external driver
really feeds into one of the most
profound things
i've ever learned from doing all this
stuff about failure
i met this man called mo gowda he used
to be the chief business officer of
google x
but he wasn't happy and he has a lot to
say about expectation
versus reality so if we can manage our
expectations of life so if they're equal
to or less than our perception of events
and how they turn out
then we can be happy or contented and
he was the one who really brought it
home to me that we are not our worst
thoughts
that our thoughts are produced by our
brain as organic matter
in the same way that blood is pumped
around our
body by our heart like we wouldn't think
we were defined by our blood so why
would we think that we are our thoughts
actually as you know the premise of all
meditation is that you can observe your
thoughts
who's doing the observing that's you
that's you
why would you need thoughts like you
don't need to communicate yourself so
your thoughts are just being produced by
your brain constantly
and i found that really helpful the idea
that
once you realize that you can train your
brain
to think differently and to replace
negative thoughts
with positive ones as much as you're
able
so he gave this incredibly moving
example his son ali died at the age of
21 during a routine operation
and in the aftermath of ali's death moe
would wake up every morning
with tears streaming down his cheeks and
his first thought would be
how he died and it was an unbelievably
oppressive
grief-stricken thought and after a few
more weeks of it he was like i just
can't live like this i can't live
like this and so he challenged his brain
to come up with a different thought
and each morning he would wake up and he
would still think and he died and he
died he'd still be crying
but he added something to that sentence
and he added
yes but he also lived and in that
differently expressed sentiment
was 21 years of memories of a father and
son who were best friends
and that was what enabled him to carry
on living and
if he can do that in that situation i
sure as hell can do it
when someone criticizes me on instagram
it was a really helpful
lesson we never really
thought sort of taught to challenge our
thinking right as you say yeah
i think it's just we think it's reality
we think it's true
and we're taught to think we need to use
it to be good at exams to get ahead to
get a good job like
that's all thought isn't it that's like
the exercise of your brain
and don't get me wrong i like love my
brain and i'm happy that i have thoughts
but
it's that thing of understanding when
they're running away
with themselves when they're in control
of you
it is the exercise of a life yeah it
like it really is trying to rise above
your own thoughts is like
yeah or at least analyze them hold them
out in front of you
and examine them for validity i mean you
mentioned working out earlier i
definitely find exercise is a helpful
way of doing that
yes like and that's something again i
never i never thought i was
good at sport and i translated that
wrongly as being like
someone who doesn't like exercise until
my 30s really until i went through all
this stuff divorce all that sort of
stuff and i needed to feel strong in
myself but that started with feeling
strong in my body
and i realized that it was just an
incredibly helpful way
of being in my body and being out of my
head and it was just such a relief
to find that isn't it that's the the way
that your brain thinks while you're
exercising versus when you're just
yeah you know in your normal life it's
just it's
bizarre it's like a different different
person shows up and can suddenly see
clearly
totally and also for me it feels like
i'm not really thinking when i'm outside
but i am i will have like processed
something that has been bothering me for
days
so fascinating i wonder why that is i
bet somebody knows just the like
monotony of doing a task or the
you know whether it's a running machine
or just lifting weights for some reason
i don't know the brain just seems to go
to a different place most of my good
ideas
if i have any come from uh come from the
gym or the
walking or the shower sometimes yeah
well that's why
people sometimes are kind enough to ask
me for writing tips like how to write
and one of the things that i say is like
don't feel guilty for not actually doing
the writing sometimes like sometimes you
literally need to
take a walk and um be around people
or be on the top deck of a double-decker
bus and look out the window
because your brain needs rest but it
also needs like
a creative fallow period where the field
is left fallow and then it becomes more
fertile in the future
and all of that feeds into your
inspiration it's so true
i you know people don't appreciate that
it's one of the real upsides of
of exercise they think it's to make
themselves look pretty but i think the
benefit i've had to my mind through
exercise is
hard to put into words maybe the only
thing that i love more in the world
than huel is salted caramel and i've got
some great news
he'll have just released their salted
caramel pure flavor
and i am over the moon because i
actually got to try this before it came
out and
genuinely no word of the lie there's
my favorite flavor of everything i've
got two favorite flavors toffee unsalted
caramel and to hear
that he'll now do salted caramel um
has made my dreams come true i've been a
heel fanatic
for the last four years as a lot of you
know it's the reason i'm in the ship
best shape of my life it's the reason
why
i have the energy i have to do this
podcast and to manage the schedule that
i have
and as we come into the summer months
and my training schedule
in the gym has started to change it's
become more important than ever that i
don't
miss some of the sort of basic
nutritional components of my diet like
proteins and like amino acids
and that is where heel fits so yeah
thank you so much and [ __ ] me salted
caramel
dream come true i want to talk about
failure
yes now which seems like a good thing to
talk about and in your book philosophy
you
you list uh seven failure principles
so i'm sure you've done this a million
times but i think it's a good
good place to start so the seven failure
principles
yes number one failure just is
yes so that actually just feeds in with
what we were talking about which is the
idea that
failure is a fact it's inevitable it's
going to happen to all of us
no matter how much we try to avoid it i
guarantee that it will happen
and that can feel scary but it can also
feel liberating because once you've
accepted it as a fact there's no point
in trying to avoid it so you might as
well take the risk
so acceptance of failure starts with the
observation of it
failure is a fact but how you respond to
it is within your control
whether you decide to feel like a
failure for
many years after the thing that's
happened or whether you think to
yourself
okay well that's taught me something and
i'll do it differently next time
i guess the risk there is one bad
failure
people stop trying exactly and then i i
was thinking this is
very similar to confidence in the way
that like if you have one bad failure
your performance next time you get an
opportunity if you actually don't manage
to just avoid it completely
will probably be worse because of nerves
and that you know the memory if i'm
terrible and yeah and then that's going
to increase your chances of failing
again
and then the kind of like self negative
reinforcing cycle kind of continues and
your
your confidence and your sort of yeah
your guts kind of
cascade downwards and can for some
people work in the other direction where
you have a success
your confidence builds you walk on stage
to do that you know public speech next
time around with a bit more
confidence you do a better job which
increases your chance of success and it
cascades upwards
is that how failure works from your
experience it can
work like that i mean to take the
example you've just given one of the
ways of looking at that if you're then
stuck in a downward cycle and you're
failing and you're trying the thing is
that you're
therefore in the wrong situation so
you're in the wrong workplace for
instance that
that isn't generous enough to like make
you feel okay after your failures or
doesn't make you feel like you can be
your true self in which case i would
argue you need to remove yourself from
that situation and find the place that
does suit you
or it can be a question of mindset
and a question of applying that mindset
that we've just talked about which is
okay i failed i'm feeling in a downward
spiral how much of that is fact
that's a very difficult thing to do on
your own when you're a very low ebb and
that's why i'm a huge advocate of
therapy
and again i know that i come from a
privileged place where
i can afford therapy but even if it
starts with
reaching out to your friend and talking
about it or reaching out to
your work helpline and talking about it
or
texting shout the mental health charity
or calling the samaritans
that's a really valuable step
and the other thing that i would say
there is that i'm very aware that
my definition of failure which is what
happens when life doesn't go according
to plan
has a fatal flaw which is that sometimes
there are failures that are totally
cataclysmic that we couldn't possibly
have predicted that go against any plan
whatsoever
like a global pandemic like a
terrible illness that you contract like
the death of a loved one
it would be monstrous for me to sit here
and say those failures
are as easily assimilated or learned
from or dealt with as fading or driving
tests and so i'm not saying that at all
those kind of failures will require a
process
of mourning and coming to terms with the
thing that you've lost
and that's absolutely right and as it
should be
my only thing is the way that i choose
to live my life is
i mourn but i don't have to constantly
relive the pain
i can still feel sadness about something
but i don't need to live in that place
of
reliving it constantly becoming a victim
yeah and becoming defined by that
i can choose to be defined by something
else i can choose to be defined
by my response to it i can choose to
find some kind of meaning in something
that was
meaningless at the time and that's how i
choose
to live my life because that makes it
less sad
and i and i think that that choice is
available for most of us
topic of conversation that i liked
having on this podcast whereas you're
alluding to there is about like personal
responsibility
and um you know we all have different
starts in life and different
you know quote-unquote advantages and
disadvantages but um
how important do you think personal
responsibility is even in times where
something happened and it's really not
your quote-unquote fault
yeah i think it's tremendously important
i want to caveat
what i'm about to say by saying i'm very
aware
that certain people are given more
opportunities to fail because of the
elitist society in which we live
because of the racist society in which
we live because of a society which
marginalizes entire groups of people
through no fault of their own
i'm aware that i as a white middle-class
woman have been given
shitloads of opportunities to fail so so
i'm totally aware of that that there's a
sliding scale
you have to say that right yeah of
course i have to say that
because because i don't want people to
think that i haven't thought about it
yeah and i also think that it's
important to have the discussion
it's crazy how many caveats we've got to
do before we say anything these days
like i don't care that much so you're
gonna get me into trouble
i find it i when i sit here and i i
speak to guests and i watch them have to
caveat something they're gonna say i
just want it so funny because i'm like i
personally
do that to some degree but i also i'm
like
are you gonna i don't know it's
interesting it's interesting because
this is a growing thing because you're
right if you hadn't have done that
someone would have yeah and someone
would think oh well it's all very well
for her to say that
and like it's just it's just a kind of
acknowledgement
that it's been easier for me in certain
respects which is fair and it's been
hard in other ways like everyone has
their own lived experience you know like
i'm talking from a place of you know i
wrote a book called how to fail which
was part memoir part manifesto
like a memoir by its nature cannot be
intersectional like i'm speaking
from my own life and i'm bringing in
voices of other people who can speak to
those experiences because it would be
delusional and offensive for me to try
has anyone ever taken that shot or
you've been like well it's easy for you
to say
oh yeah does it feel um be honest
how does it feel well okay
it did feel before i'd done the thinking
like an attack it did feel like
well hang on a second i have worked hard
to be where i am and actually if you
only knew
like there are things that i never talk
about or write about that will never be
in the public domain because they
involve other people
okay so i just can't i choose not to go
there
and then and then i read more about it
and talk more about it and
it's absolutely true that
i have had massive advantages in my life
and that's a fact as is the fact that
i've worked hard as well but i did have
those advantages
so for me to deny that feels
really wrong and actually irresponsible
and um now i feel like
there's a certain dialogue that is had
around women
where i feel women are more often
challenged for talking about their
personal experiences
than men are and maybe you can tell me
that no i think you're telling the truth
i think i would agree
okay and i don't like that that's crazy
that's so true
yeah it's so true like i don't like the
fact that i
feel as though i constantly have to say
i constantly have to show my battle
scars and my
wounds and my sadness in order to
earn the right to a platform from which
i can speak and write
as a woman now there are certain
white middle class privately educated
men out there
who never have to do that apologizing
they never have to do that caveat
people just like oh they're quirky but
they all say it with that
they will like the quote is like say
with your chest they will say it with
their chest they'll talk about their
success they'll give advice
they don't caveat anything it's like
this is how you do it
and it's funny because i sat here with
um
maybe shouldn't say their name but i sat
here with a young lady who's very
successful
yeah and she was educated at maybe the
best university in the last race
perfectly yes
i heard it i listened to it yeah and i
thought she dealt with it very elegantly
and why she got to deal with elegantly
and uh i sit here i think
like this the point i was trying to make
to her is like
why is it that you and grace have to
have to like
do this like assault course of words and
caveats because you will
someone will say in the comments section
oh it's very easy for but with
my male guests no they don't do that and
they don't have to and they don't get
attacked
can i ask you an off-topic personal
question
about race on the record on the record
totally on the record
so i felt really conflicted
on social media around
black lives matter and the horrendous
tragic
to my mind a legal death of george floyd
and i was like
but i don't i felt like i don't need to
post on instagram
that i think killing black people is bad
like surely that's a given
no no no elizabeth silence is violence
i'm taking them first i know but i do so
i would love to hear from you like
what's my
responsibility because i did post a
black square because i was like if i
don't post a black square then that
i don't that feels wrong to me as well i
mean but this is just like this is
a huge issue with society because
um we're thinking in such binary
[ __ ] ways about these really complex
sensitive systemic issues
it's in that moment and the reason i did
this post on instagram it went viral and
like
everyone's seen it and i've talked about
this podcast multiple times mainly
because i just had adults on so i've
talked about it there but
obviously when uh we watch a
a a black man get killed for nine
minutes asking for his mum
any sound sort of morally sound
human being on planet earth will feel a
bunch of emotions i watched it
and i didn't say anything for three days
because i just i just didn't want to see
that [ __ ] clip again
no i didn't want to talk about it i
watched that clip and just thought oh i
felt sick to my stomach and i was angry
and i was sad and i just didn't want to
and then my dms in my dms i've got all
these dms from people black people going
you've not stood with us you [ __ ] but
i'm just thinking oh [ __ ] off like
yeah i mean this isn't and in those
moments what social media in the world
will try and do
is it will try and make you um fit
exactly
into a a camp that that think
in one way that act in one way that use
one hashtag that post one thing
and i will not and i will not and so in
that moment what i posted was defending
white people i guess or everyone and
said listen people process things in
their own ways and that's normal
obviously do you agree with that
statement people process
especially traumatic things in their own
everyone agrees with that sentence
and some people might be thinking they
might be reading they might just be
listening
and that's okay and also my last point
here is
i'm gonna be black forever for my entire
life my kids will also be have a little
bit of black in them too
maybe a quarter black depending on who i
marry um
and uh so if you actually give a [ __ ]
about changing things your response
isn't a black tile
your response would be something much
more systemic your response might be
educating yourself and your friends
get virtue signaling on social media
that for me that's a sign that you
probably don't really care
yeah if anything and like you can't say
that unless you're black
i'm the only person that can say that
like i'm not the only one
there's more of us but i mean like i'm
in my friendship group i'm the only one
because you'd be all of you be finished
off every single one of you would get
finished
if you said anything like that so and
and then
it's a saddle while we live because i
know everyone in this room agrees
not one of you can say it and that's a
sad place to be where
this isn't a war of ideas this is a war
of like virtue signaling
like we're not it's not competition of
the best ideas it's a it's a competition
of like
who is correct and who is incorrect
cancel accept
cancel accept and man oh what a sad
place
can't even have a conversation without
someone's [ __ ] gonna lose your job
i'm fortunately unemployed
so no one can find me and i don't really
need the money either so
like you know what i mean like the
podcast sponsors if they thought i was
immoral or whatever they could pull out
but
now i think thank you because that's i
think you're right and i think
compassion and nuance can't be
fitted into the binary world of social
media a lot of the time
never i'm really sorry because i've
completely like
really taken
the thing that annoys me more is i don't
think it can be fixed
i don't know i don't know how it can be
fixed i know the way that algorithms
work and i know that they create echo
chambers where everyone thinks like you
so the minute anyone in your echo
chamber is not thinking like you
uh you the way that they reinforce
and reward your thought using these
algorithms
you're not gonna get rewarded you're
gonna get attacked and so it's it's
fighting against it's fighting a losing
battle at some point i'll probably be
cancelled for something
i'm like pretty aware of this because i
refuse to
i like to think in nuance i like to
think i don't think left or right i
think
usually the truth is somewhere in the
middle often yeah more so than it is
on the far left or the far right and
that is a dangerous way to think
is it's a crime and for me that's a form
of imprisonment which is the
the inability to think and speak for
yourself that's a form of imprisonment
in the same way
putting someone in a cage it's and for
me also not allowing people to express
themselves we've seen the harm that does
we've seen when people can't express
their sexuality they kill themselves
more
so i will i was thinking i was like i
will not allow
myself to be imprisoned my thought to be
imprisoned and my expression to be put
in impressive because i actually think
the net
impact of that is much worse than just
someone who's someone writing some [ __ ]
in the comments section about me i'd
like to be a
free thinker what do you think of piers
morgan
sometimes he hits sometimes he misses
he's got he's a bit of a narcissist in
some ways
sometimes he's like right sometimes he's
wrong sometimes i agree sometimes i
don't yeah
shouldn't be de-platformed we can all
scream at him but um he's not
he's not like he's not a racist
he's not um doing it he's not like
encouraging people to like
hurt each other he's not encouraging
harm or violence he has an opinion which
some people disagree with sometimes
talking about sharon osborne she's been
chucked off her show for defending
pierce morgan
and i watched the clip last night of um
what she said and all she goes is
you know what has he said that's racist
and the host responds to him it's not
what he said he hasn't said anything
racist
it's just his you know basically his
attitude towards the situation
oh come on [ __ ] hell but do you think
so but do you think that because we've
had millennia of things
one way the transitional phase is always
going to have to be extreme as the
pendulum swings
to one to one end and so that it can
then
stabilize in the center and we're just
living through an age of transition
i like to think that sometimes but then
i know how algorithms work and i think
that the algorithms are reinforcing our
echo chambers
every single day my algorithm is telling
me if i'm
right or if i'm wrong and it's based on
group think it's like these pockets of
group think
and the other thing is like just what i
think about it logically i think you
know i read this quote one day and it
was like if
your opinions and beliefs almost
identically resemble
the people around you then they're not
your opinions and beliefs
i thought about that a lot and i was
like that's really interesting
yeah if we want to get like really deep
about this
yeah most of our beliefs and opinions
come from the society we live in and
you've only got to go back five thousand
ten thousand years and see the barbaric
things we did
that we thought were morally sound and
okay
to realize that in fact our opinions and
beliefs are mainly given to us by
society
in fact good and bad if you look at what
we did a hundred years ago if you look
at what happened in certain parts of the
world in
you know history those people thought
they were good
and that was the right thing to do and
so what are my opinions today the
majority what social media and the world
has told me is the correct
thing to do how moral are we if we felt
completely moral
when we used to like behead people and
kill black people a topic from anyway
what was that
i'm so sorry number two of fail
philosophy
i like lost my way in this quickly yeah
got the list here as well
so point number two in your book is you
are not your anxious brain i think
you've talked about that
almost everything phil feels they almost
everyone feels they have failed in their
twenties
i mean not you okay so it's stephen i'm
pretty sure
do you think you failed in your 20s
probably personally
sorry multiple no no no it's a good
question actually
multiple times yeah yeah started my
first business at 18 it was clearly a
failure
left that when i was 20 years old failed
in order relationships fail every day in
business
not the big like momentous failures
other than my business that one would
assert but probably more than anybody to
be fair i think
that's so great to hear yeah and also i
think that a lot of people struggle in
their 20s
particularly in this day and age because
of the curse of comparison
and because we live in a culture of
curated perfection where you're
constantly comparing yourself to your
peers
filtered appearance on instagram and the
life that they seem to be living so
we're comparing our insides with
everyone else's projection of their
outside
exactly yeah and for many people
although i know not you but for many
people it's the first time that they've
come out of full-time education and come
out of a system
of exam and reward exam and reward
and there is no exam that you can sit to
show that you're being a good grown-up
so you feel quite lost plus piling on
top of that
the pressure to find your passion
to like make a career for yourself but
also to earn enough to pay your rent
living in house shares like just trying
to make your way
and trying to forge your identity in
this day and age it's just so hard to do
all that at once
and then you're like oh and i should be
having like a thriving personal life and
i should either be in a long-term
relationship or
having one night sounds and making
footloose and fancy-free and drinking
modes and then
at the weekend making vegan brownies
because i got to watch what i eat and
all of that sort of stuff
and it's exhausting and so really
what i wanted to say in that failure
principle was that so many people come
on podcast and say that they feel they
failed at their 20s
and i think a lot of us fall into the
trap and i did too of believing that we
had to have our life sorted out by then
and actually your twenties are a decade
of transition of discovering who you are
of grinding up the spices of life in
your pestle and water
and the older you get my experience has
been the more you know yourself and the
more you know what you want to do and
that's where success lies i've had so
many more opportunities
after leaving my 20s behind in the rear
view mirror
wow everything else i've had you've
really thought about that you wrote a
book on it so
yeah um number four breakups are not a
tragedy
your ex-partner has taught you something
yeah one of the things you said which i
which i thought was really really
powerful is that um a relationship
ending doesn't mean that it failed
that's it in a nutshell like i've had
countless failed relationships and and
they and they
and it sucks like heartbreak there is no
pain like heartbreak
i hate it it's the worst isn't it it's
the worst it really i
yeah i totally relate and
i now realize that i learned something
very instructive from each one of those
relationships
and from the fact that they ended it
taught me something that i needed to
know
about myself and i realized that
love that was ready for me i didn't need
to fight to convince it
like it would meet me where i was and it
might not come in the package that i
expected and it didn't
i i met justin on a hinge date that i
almost didn't go on
and it doesn't and it doesn't
immediately feel
like the thing that you thought you
wanted because actually that hasn't
worked out for you
so it's always better to make a
different choice i think so yeah it's
just about how
although relationships feel that they
might be life-ending at the time they
never never
when they end they never never are and
often someone has been sent to you
whether it be a friendship a work
colleague or a lover
to teach you a lesson that you needed to
know and when a relationship ends
it's because you've been taught that
lesson god it's a shitty lesson to learn
and also like
when you when you go through a breakup
as you've described there um
not letting it end is part in my
experience of the reason why something
new doesn't start
yes oh that's so yes that's what oprah
would call a teachable moment
yeah you need to you need to create the
space
for the new thing to come in which means
leaving something behind what i talk
about a little bit
before about quitting being just as much
of a skill in an art form as starting we
glamorize
starting but there's a real talent not
yet
there's a real skill to knowing how to
quit how to move forward because
you know starting is great but the thing
you do before you start something is to
quit something else and yeah
that is i i mean just from reading your
books and stuff and listening to the
the interviews you've done not
appreciated enough
because it involves uncertainty you're
throwing yourself off a cliff sometimes
and building the paraglider as you fly
yes and we're also taught
to avoid feelings of sadness like good
vibes only and you're like no actually
sometimes you need to
be in that sadness you need to feel that
discomfort to understand what life
really is life
is texture life is all sorts of emotions
and when we feel grief
because a relationship has ended or
because we've lost someone
that as that famous quote says is the
price you pay for love and in a way it's
a beautiful thing to feel
because it's a signifier of how much you
loved
just sucks though i know it just doesn't
it just suck like i
just giving people advice from
heartbreak i feel like it's such a for
me
when i'm like in my dms and someone sent
me something about i've just broken up
with this person and whatever
yeah it's such an intoxicating
force like heartbreak yeah that i'm like
my words aren't going to help you
you just basically have to tough it out
and to and to try as much as you can
in believing that your future will be
better yeah you'll get past this
and believing that rejection is
protection if you're rejected
yes that person is not for you
either because they've been stupid
enough to [ __ ] reject you
or because action is character and if
they've dumped you it's like
well do you really want to trust that
person for the rest of your life no i'm
gonna
is is that is that true and i'm playing
devil's advocate here intentionally
because i'd actually know the answer
it if you get rejected is that person
not right
for you it i mean yes i think but
i suppose it depends on the nature of
the rejection like it has to be a
serious one
um it can't just be an unread what's
whatsapp message like
that you're interpreting as a rejection
they like
full-on rejected yeah i think that's
listen i don't know if it's true or not
but it's what i choose to believe
because it makes me feel better about
life to believe i think that you're
the definition you gave of like well
they didn't appreciate you
yeah what about like how if we
think about taking responsibility in
those situations and we say okay my
relationship with this guy that i loved
ended
because i have problems because not when
i say problems
like i have jealousy or i have things
that i haven't dealt with
is that also you know that so it's hard
for people to do that yeah lame is super
easy in heartbreak
you're so right and that's where
personal responsibility comes in yeah
and so in the immediate aftermath of a
breakup
you're going to probably feel
heartbroken
and really sad once you've processed
that
then it's then your responsibility
is to understand what part you played in
the dynamic
but for those first few weeks do
whatever you need to do to get through
and if you need to blame someone
and just keep saying rejection is
protection like what a loser
do it because you just need to get
through that initial
phase of awfulness i actually
my last serious breakup i was in
such a dark place i googled how long
does it take to get over heartbreak
it's like actually that was a really
good
six weeks i did feel better it was a
good it was like a manageable length of
time
and i was like okay i'm gonna feel
miserable for six weeks and once
you commit to the acceptance of that it
becomes a lot easier to deal with
because you're not struggling against
feeling it you're like well i'm on track
because i'm now week four so yeah i'm
still feeling miserable that's okay and
it somehow makes you feel better
no i get that yeah are you post-breakup
right now um not post-breakup no
uh i'm i'm post um something ending
okay um i'm sorry no no it wasn't it was
it was um i consider it to be a choice
that i made
okay yeah so that's not necessarily the
best example for me
the the real significant heartbreak
moments i had were all when i was when i
was younger really
and uh yeah and it just always sucked um
but obviously i've got a lot of friends
that are going through breakups and
stuff and it's always difficult to
give them advice because you're they're
so their head is gone like there's no
way i can describe it
there's no sense there when in matters
of love it's just all
so yeah just asking them to tough it out
i think is is all i've ever got in terms
of it well now you can give them a copy
there you go point number seven
when we choose to share our
vulnerabilities is when we feel most
satisfaction most connection i think
is what i said well i don't why does it
say satisfaction on momentum i like that
too
because you probably do feel personal
satisfaction it's like but when
we choose to be open about our
vulnerabilities
that's paradoxically when we find the
most strength and the source of the most
real connections with other people
amen yeah and that's something that i
have genuinely learned through the
podcast the first season of the podcast
i did
i was very much i came from a very
traditional newspaper journalist
background
so for me it was like i'm interviewing
my guest
i will ask the questions and i will
listen and then i will ask another
question
and it was only as time went on that i
felt more comfortable
sharing my own experiences and whenever
i did that i had such an incredible
like feedback loop of like just
amazing people sharing their stories and
their vulnerabilities
and also saying that they felt less
alone because i shared mine
and really that's what my entire life is
about
ultimately is connection and so
i really want to encourage people not to
be scared of opening up about the things
that they perceive as their weaknesses
because so often what you think of as
your most personal
shame turns out to have most universal
resonance
and that was certainly my experience
talking about fertility and miscarriage
and divorce
like actually that's where i've had
the greatest impact i think and i'm so
grateful for that
why do you think that is why do you
think vulnerable in terms of like why it
has such wide resonance
why do you think that is because i think
that when we're vulnerable we're being
real
and we're letting our masks slip and
you'll see a glimpse of who
the authentic person is and there's
something
just absolutely quintessentially human
about that
so it's a human recognizing another
human it's a human recognizing another
human
beneath the pretense and i think
it also reassures people because as
we've been talking about in this culture
that we live in which is so defined by
social media
and how you appear and the
currency of perfection again it's such a
relief it makes you feel like you can
breathe and someone's like oh god
i'll tell you about today i sat in bed
in my pajamas eating hummus direct from
the top because i felt really down
that's an act of singular generosity to
someone else who can then have the space
to talk about how they're feeling is
there any such thing as too vulnerable
or over sharing there's uh there's
i don't think there's any such thing as
too vulnerable i do think there is such
a thing as oversharing
and i only say i i say i make that
distinction because
over sharing is about telling your story
to others
and obviously there are right and
appropriate times and places to do that
i'm not advocating that someone goes
into work and just starts sobbing at
their desk
there's there's definitely a time and
place for that but i wouldn't suggest
doing that every single day
like to protect yourself you need to
find a safe space that you can
share those vulnerabilities with and
then build up your strength and your
confidence and realize what it is that
you do want to speak more publicly about
because i don't think that you can
share with everyone immediately
after you've experienced pain like
that's too soon
and also you can't trust everyone to
honor what you're sharing
so i don't think you can be too
vulnerable but it's a question of
choosing the things that you then take
your vulnerability
and share from and who you share them
with that was such an ineloqua
no it was good no no it's a reason
basically about that no yeah i
completely i completely
i was thinking when you were saying it
because i remember having a conversation
with one of my team members in new york
one day where
um i was trying to you know the the
issue you have when you're a ceo
um is someone might have some struggles
some mental health issues or they might
have some problems going on at home
how do you tell them without being a
dick
to to not broadcast that every day to
their team
yeah below them but also knowing the
importance of
speaking an expression is part of the
cure so i remember having a conversation
with one particular person and just
saying to them like the key thing is
like
knowing the right outlet for that yes
and you've described it as
like the safe space exactly and that can
be
a different safe space for different
people it can be your therapist it can
be
your sibling it can be um the in-house
therapy that your workplace hopefully
provides
but i also think that it goes back to
what we were saying earlier
if a team leader is in that position i
think it's about
being able to bring your authentic whole
self to work
but being able to show that you're not
defined by the things that have gone
wrong
or if you are defined by it or defined
in a good way
in that you're choosing to lean into
this particular feeling because it's
going to teach you something that you
need to know
that's the sort of responsibility of a
leader i think it's not to pretend that
everything's fine
and to wear this mask of the perfect
boss
it's to be someone who acknowledges that
life can be touched tough and who
shares what they're going to do about
that i think we need to have confidence
in our leaders that they
have an idea about what to do with it
when they're sharing it in the workplace
and this is the problem with matt
hancock being such a robot isn't it oh
my gosh
didn't even get me started on that i
don't know if he experiences emotion i
should probably shouldn't say that
because that's unfair but i just i look
at this guy and i think
do you understand what people are
feeling i don't think you do
it's the problem with so many
politicians i was so inspired by angela
merkel recently because she apologized
for having overturned a
lockdown ruling over easter she's like
i'm really sorry i got that wrong
i was like oh my gosh thank you thank
you
just quickly just go back to over
sharing and jacinda
oh my gosh jacinda is i mean
we both need to get her on our
perspective podcasts we really do
um over sharing as it pertains to women
just very quickly
i think women are often shamed into
silence
and i've definitely experienced that so
i'm being like why do you talk about all
this stuff why don't you keep it private
and i'm like precisely so that i attack
that kind of narrative
because i feel that so many people
feel shame and stigma over things they
don't need to feel it for and it's
because people stay silent
so i think it's also a bit of a stick
with which to beat women
i completely agree is there anything
you wouldn't share that doesn't
involve someone else oh that's a great
question
because every time i every time you hit
a wall in terms of what you're willing
to share
it's because you say well that involves
someone else so i won't share but is
there anything about yourself
that you wouldn't share that doesn't
involve anybody else
i am still determined to be a mother
um when i get pregnant
i will have i don't think i would share
that
publicly because i would feel
fearful and anxious and also because i
have such respect
for women who
are going through fertility issues that
i would just never do that
but that involves another person
the one that i'm carrying so i'm not
sure
whether the parameters your question
really fit right but that is one thing
that i've thought about
yeah so that's quite a heavy answer
that's a really interesting point there
about the you wouldn't want to share it
because
you've probably um resonated
well of course you are [ __ ] probably
you've resonated with a lot of women who
are going through that same experience
and you've probably got a lot of those
people in your audience so
for some of those people it might i mean
you know humans are humans
the news that you know when you have
your your own child might feel
like [ __ ] to them definitely and i
respect that because i've been there
and i felt it and i feel it still and
and i totally understand that i feel it
as in
it's like a jealousy of it's like an
envy yes yes
of women that have a child or that yeah
i mean it's not
it's never personally directed it's just
a sort of
envy or yearning would be a better word
for an experience that thus far has been
denied me
and i think lockdown and the pandemic
has been so hard
for all women
and it's been incredibly hard for people
homeschooling their children
but for people who don't have children
and desperately
long for that for people who are going
through fertility treatment that's been
delayed by
the pandemic for people who've
experienced miscarriages during lockdown
as i have it's incredibly painful to see
parents complaining about homeschooling
and how
difficult that is to have these children
that they have to homeschool that's a
very difficult thing now
no one is to blame for that i take
personal responsibility for my reaction
and that's where i need to curate my
social media feed that is
absolutely not the thought of the parent
question they should totally do that and
lean into it and that is completely
right and appropriate
that's up to me to take that
responsibility on it's just that i know
i wouldn't feel comfortable shouting it
from the rooftops because i know how
[ __ ] painful and traumatic it is to
go through i really do
listen so your um your vulnerability and
your honesty is is really moving
and it's very very rare and you know i
can't i can't even begin to
imagine how many um people women
you've helped because of your
vulnerability you probably don't even
get to see it
so i want to thank you on behalf of all
those people as i was reading about your
story and your journey
i was like really taken aback by how
open and honest you're willing to be
because you don't need to be right
um i'm sure that you know as you've
described in some of the things you've
written
you've you've discovered that it's
actually really almost paradoxically
quite a selfish thing
to be so selfless in that way but um
yeah i think you're just remarkable and
i think um
what you've written and the work you've
produced is phenomenal and i just wanted
to thank you so much for coming here
today and being as vulnerable
with me as you have been across all of
your other work it's um it's truly uh
you know we're it's it's fortunate we're
fortunate as a society to have people
like you in it
so thank you thank you for giving me a
safe space
and for making me feel like i can be
vulnerable with you
i have loved this conversation so much i
really truly have
and i love that i've been able to swear
but i also love what you do and what you
stand for and honestly your instagram
page
i don't know how you have so much wisdom
at such a young age
but we will find your perfect match all
right please
please do your book philosophy it's um
everywhere i actually went down to the
same pancreas yesterday just to get it
got it off the shelf i think uh
excellent yeah um
where else can people find you and what
else are you working on that they should
check out the podcast as well how to
fail
yes that's a smash hit book sunday times
bestseller
yes uh i wrote another book before that
called how to fail
originally everything i've ever learned
from things going wrong which is my
memoir
part memoir part manifesto the podcast
available on all podcast platforms um
i'm on social media at
elizabeth day and i've got a novel out
my new novel is out in september and
it's called magpie
and um it is okay
i have to be a bit vague because there's
a massive twist in it okay
and it's a sort of psychological twisty
novel
but it's about a lot of what we've been
talking about today it's about
dysfunctional motherhood and what
happens when you
think you know what you want and then
your dreams come true and then it just
turns out to be
a total illusion have i sold it
is it a thriller yeah it is it's
basically a thriller driven by kind of
warped characters okay interesting
and i'm obsessed with magpies that's why
it's called magpie okay
sorry do you salute magpie i don't know
i don't think i know
no one ever told me that tell but um
thank you so much again and it means
well to me that you can make the time
for this today and i'm
sure that you've imparted a ton of
important inspiration on our listeners
so thank you
thank you for having me
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you